con un mensaje televisado de la
ciudadanía el presidente Gabriel borit
presentó la noche del miércoles las
claves de lo que será su reforma de
pensiones en ella plantea un sistema
mixto en el que tanto el estado como los
trabajadores como los empresarios algo
que no ocurre en la actualidad
aportarían a las cotizaciones que se
incrementarían de esta forma un 6% y que
de ser aprobada esta reformaría que los
chilenos percibieran unas pensiones un
46% más altas en el caso de los hombres
y un 52% más altas en el caso de las
mujeres puesto que también se establecen
mecanismos de compensación para paliar
las injusticias que sufren las mujeres
en la actualidad En este terreno como un
retroceso ha sido calificada por la
administración de fondos de pensiones
que controlan las pensiones en la
actualidad un sistema que Data de la
dictadura y que ha sido un sistema
privado en su mayoría por su parte la
oposición critica la letra chica el
hecho de que no se permite a los
ciudadanos optar entre un sistema
público o un sistema privado y también
algunos de los mecanismos que se
plantean en esta reforma la gran duda es
si la reforma que se al congreso en la
próxima semana contará con los votos de
todos los partidos para salir adelante
en un congreso extremadamente dividido
donde el gobierno no cuenta con las
mayorías mucho más cuando es una reforma
que está sujeta a otra de las grandes
reformas del gobierno de Boris la
reforma tributaria que aún se debate en
el congreso de ser aprobada esta reforma
solucionaría muchas de las demandas que
aquejan a los ciudadanos chilenos en las
últimas cuatro décadas